just as the governor was announcing
changes to those large gatherings mgm
resorts are releasing a health and
safety protocol for meetings and
conventions at its properties
definitely other properties tonight are
probably working on their plans as well
joe muller joining us now live from the
strip and joe this was definitely some
really good news
for so many people that are out of work
yeah that's right this announcement
hopefully means better things to come
especially for the thousands of people
who have been out of work for about six
months now
having all of these people out of work
is a huge blow to the economy
michael mckean is a convention stagehand
he has been out of work since the
pandemic put a stop to conventions
even a few days a week means
people don't have to collect
unemployment mckean is hopeful many can
return to some sort of work soon
especially with mgm resorts safety plan
released tuesday
the convene with confidence covers
everything from arrivals to physical
distancing
it also details an optional health
screening plan that includes a 20-minute
copic 19 test
it starts sending a signal that we're
going to get back we're coming back
and you can start planning your events
thousands of people are waiting for the
news that could help them get back to
work we've had to pivot
multiple times during this pandemic as
most people have
we've cut down our
workforce quite a bit michelle rothstein
owns balloons with a twist
large events like conventions is where
she makes the most money
she thinks people can get back to work
in a safe manner i'd like to see that
come back
and i'd like to see it done safely and i
think there is a way for that to be done
now back out here live both of those
people you just heard there said they
did expect some changes when convection
conventions were allowed to return they
say with this announcement today they
can hopefully get more work
here soon reporting live near the las
vegas strip joe mohler 8 news now
thank you joe so the big reason why we